las últimas cifras son asombrosas según
los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses se registraron alrededor
de 200.000 nuevos casos y más de 3.500
muertes en eeuu en las últimas 24 horas
los ángeles el condado más poblado de la
nación es el más afectado every hour
cada hora en promedio dos de nuestros
vecinos familiares o amigos mueren a
causa de colitis 9
thain sein con el número de personas
hospitalizadas por kobe 19 x casi 6
desde noviembre los funcionarios de
salud están instando a la gente a no
reunirse durante las vacaciones de fin
de año para detener la cadena de
contagios
estamos viendo el impacto de lo que pasó
en el día de acción de gracias parece
que no hay suficiente gente que haya
escuchado y seguido el mensaje de
quedarse en casa y evitar reunirse con
otro anders en california los hospitales
están al límite de sus capacidades sólo
el 4% de las uci están disponibles
son machistas hay tanto estrés en
nosotros las enfermeras y los médicos y
todos los trabajadores de la salud están
realmente trabajando tan duro a través
de esto
horas y horas y horas por día sin parar
no está el despliegue de las vacunas ha
proporcionado un rayo de esperanza el
primer lote de 29 millones de dosis de
la vacuna facer variante que comenzó a
ser administrado a los prioritarios el
lunes se espera que una segunda vacuna
de moderna gane la aprobación de uso de
emergencia de la administración en los
próximos días las autoridades
advirtieron a los ciudadanos que no
bajen la guardia en menos de un año el
nuevo coronavirus ha infectado a casi 17
millones de personas en estados unidos
lo que equivale al 5% de la población